[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
niedrigen schönen guten abend ihnen
allen und wieder bei mir für den sport
ist kristin otto vorfreude guten abend
dann blicken wir gemeinsam auf unserer
heutigen themen
bangen vor dem jahrestag die ukraine
fürchtet dass russland 77 jahre nach
ende des zweiten weltkriegs seine
angriffe ab morgen ausweiten könnte
historischer erfolg in nordirland bei
regionalwahlen gewinnt die
nationalistische sinn fein partei
haushoch
und rückkehr aus dem all matthias maurer
ist wieder in deutschland und schildert
seinen blick auf den planeten im
krisenmodus
es ist eine traurige situation die
ukraine gedenken morgen der opfer des
zweiten weltkriegs gleichzeitig erleidet
sie hohe verluste durch den russischen
angriffskrieg wieder haben raketen die
hafenstadt odessa getroffen aus dem
stahlwerk in mariupol haben es heute
offenbar die letzten zivilisten
herausgeschafft aber die angst ist groß
dass russlands militär die attacken zum
tag des sieges über nazi deutschland
verschärft alexandra vacano
es soll eine demonstration militärischer
stärke werden die sieges parade auf dem
roten platz in moskau mit panzern
raketensystemen flugshow heute nochmal
generalprobe währenddessen neue
russische raketen angriffe am mittag auf
die süd ukrainische hafenstadt odessa es
soll ein militärflugplatz getroffen
worden seien in der ukraine wächst nun
auch die angst dass die russen das
stahlwerk in mario pohl bis montag
erobern wollen inzwischen sind wohl alle
frauen kinder und ältere aus dem
stahlwerk evakuiert worden heißt es aus
kiew und der ukrainische präsident hofft
auf die rettung der soldaten
wir arbeiten auch einen diplomatischen
optionen um unser militär zu retten das
sich immer noch in as of style aufhält
einflussreiche vermittler sind beteiligt
einflussreiche staaten
der bevorstehende 93 kiews bürgermeister
vitali klitschko waren in den kommenden
tagen besteht eine hohe
wahrscheinlichkeit von raketenbeschuss
in allen regionen der ukraine seien sie
vorsichtig und achten sie auf ihre
sicherheit
von der ostfront vermelden die ukraine
das keine russischen durchbrüche trotz
täglichen beschusses
dafür sollen die besatzer eine
abspaltung von herzen und russische
pässe für die menschen in der
südukrainischen
russland ist für immer hier daran sollte
kein zweifel bestehen es wird keine
rückkehr in die vergangenheit geben so
ein vertreter der kreml-partei es ist
tag 73 im krieg und die ukraine schaut
mit großem bangen auf die nächsten tage
richtung moskau
gehen mit so katrin eigendorf nach kiel
für kathrin i russen feiern am neunten
mal den tag des sieges über
nazi-deutschland die ukraine gedenken am
achten bei der kriegsopfer womit ist an
beiden tagen zu rechnen
also der tag morgen wird hier im ganz im
zeichen einer abspaltung von der
gemeinsamen erinnerungskultur stehen die
ukraine setzt damit ein zeichen und sagt
es gibt keine gemeinsame geschichte mit
russland es gibt keinen gemeinsamen
feiertag wir gedenken hier der opfer des
zweiten weltkrieges am 8 mai zusammen
mit polen zum beispiel während russland
an diesem tag den sieg über nazi
deutschland feiert was die ukraine mit
großer sorge sieht denn putin wird an
diesem tag natürlich auch den krieg
gegen die ukraine in den mittelpunkt
stellen der für ihn ja eine art
fortsetzung des sieges über nazi
deutschland ist er sieht ja auch hier
eine vermeintlich faschistische
regierung an der macht dir entmachten
will deswegen sieht man den tag hier mit
großer sorge es gibt viele warnungen
auch hier in kiel wo es bislang relativ
ruhig ist dass man hier aufpassen soll
man rechnet auch hier wieder mit
möglichen raketenangriffen live aus kiew
katrin eigendorf vielen dank wir schauen
jetzt nach kharkiv dass er lange als
frontstaat galt zu hunderttausenden sind
die einwohner aus der stadt geflohen und
dort hat nicht das blatt jetzt gewendet
die ukraine drängt die russischen
angreifer nämlich zurück und konnte
mehrere vororte zurückerobern
mittlerweile ist tragisch dass nur 20
kilometer von der russischen grenze
entfernt liegt zur zuflucht geworden für
menschen aus den umkämpften gebieten im
osten und ginzel und michael haselrieder
berichten wir sind in hd für besuchen
eine unterkunft für ukrainische
flüchtlinge aus den kampfgebieten aller
ist zum ersten mal wieder beim friseur
zwei monate hat sie im keller gelebt
während draußen bomben viel
wir hatten kaum etwas zu essen brot gab
es zwei monate nicht
natalia ist erst vor ein paar tagen aus
ihrem dorf direkt an der front geflohen
sie zeigt uns ein video
neben unserem haus ist eine bombe
eingeschlagen nur 10 bis 15 meter
entfernt wir waren gerade im keller da
haben wir beschlossen zu fliegen die
häuser haben gebrannt alles hat gebrannt
auch viele kinder sind den angriffen
entkommen sie malen um ihre erfahrungen
zu verarbeiten erzählen uns von
russischen soldaten
es sind sehr schlechte menschen sind
männer die schießen
sie kommen in die häuser und nehmen die
männer mit sie schießen auf menschen zu
schießen mit panzern auf die häuser sie
schießen auch auf autos
ihre mütter berichten russische kämpfer
hätten junge ukrainische männer bedroht
und sie mitgenommen unabhängig
überprüfen lässt sich das nicht
sie haben ihre hände und füße mit
klebeband gefesselt von vielen jungs die
sie nach russland über die grenze
gebracht haben wissen wir nicht wo sie
sind niemand weiß ob sie noch leben oder
nicht diese frauen und ihre kinder sind
weg von der front doch in sicherheit
sind sie nicht auch um hartz iv wird
noch gekämpft
russische menschenrechtler haben in
stuttgart den theodor heuss preis
bekommen er geht in diesem jahr an die
organisation memorial
mitbegründerin scherbakowa sagte man
könne den machthaber nur die kraft der
schwachen entgegensetzen memorial
engagiert sich unter anderem für die
aufarbeitung politischer
gewaltherrschaft und für die
überlebenden sowjetische arbeitslager in
russland ist die organisation seit
dezember verboten
im jüngsten zdf politbarometer zur
morgigen schleswig-holstein-wahl können
die cdu und ihr ministerpräsident
günther auf gute zustimmungswerte
blicken das zdf wahlstudio in kiel mit
hochrechnungen analysen und ergebnissen
geht am morgen auf sendung bettina
schausten ist natürlich jetzt schon da
bettina gerade schon erwähnt anja
günther hat ein deutliches umfrage
polster was wird das spannende morgen
bei der wahl
also zunächst mal muss die cdu mit
ministerpräsident günther den sieg auch
einfahren
denn wenn die wähler meinen die sache
sei gelaufen kann der erfolg weniger
glanzvoll ausfallen als erwartet
zweitens wird es ein spannendes rennen
geben um platz zwei die grünen sind an
die spd heran gerückt die morgen mit
einem historisch schlechten ergebnis
rechnen muss nur sechs wochen nachdem
spd kantersieg im saarland ja und dann
ist da die große frage nach der neuen
regierung hier im norden jamaika steht
gut da wird aber wohl geschichte sein
wenn es für zwei partner reicht schwarz
grün ist da eine perspektive aber
überraschungen nicht ausgeschlossen
alles gründe morgen dabei zu sein vor
allem geht es um das signal aus kiel
nach düsseldorf nächsten sonntag wird in
nordrhein westfalen gewählt wo die lage
deutlich knapper aussieht also es lohnt
sich einzuschalten wir melden uns morgen
ab 17 und 40 aus dem wahlstudio hier an
der kieler förde bis dann vielen dank
und bis morgen bettina chancen wir
schauen jetzt auf die regionalwahlen in
großbritannien genauer in die provinz
nordirland das ergebnis das darf man
historisch nennen denn die schon fein
partei liegt uneinholbar vorne sie galt
einst als politischer arm der ira einer
terror-organisation die jahrzehntelang
mit bombenanschlägen gewaltsam für eine
vereinigung nordirlands mit der republik
und kämpfte bis
1998 dann das karfreitagsabkommen den
bürgerkrieg beendete jetzt könnte schön
fans sogar nordirlands neue
regierungschefin stellen andreas stamm
berichtet
100 jahre nordirische geschichte auf den
kopf gestellt ein jubelmeer schimpfen
stärkste kraft im parlament zum ersten
mal siegen die die eine vereinigung mit
der republik irland wollt
ich bestärke alle die die vereinigung
noch nicht sehen lasst uns reden eine
sachliche debatte darüber führen wie
unsere zukunft aussehen soll kein
triumphgeheul denn um regierungschefin
zu werden braucht es die zustimmung der
größten unionistenpartei die op eine
besonderheit teil des friedensabkommens
von 98 doch die unionisten hatten
angekündigt lieber keine regierung ein
politisches vakuum als juniorpartner
sein für schimpfen weil das ihren
größten albtraum näher bringen könnte
nordirland nicht mehr britisch sondern
irischen könnte auch bei den wahlen in
irland stärkste kraft werden dass in
beiden teilen zu sein wäre ein
deutlicher schritt richtung vereinigung
aber die britische regierung wird eine
volksabstimmung darüber erst zustimmen
wenn sich eine mehrheit für die
vereinigung abzeichnet und die gibt es
noch nicht
weiterer streitpunkt nordirland
sonderstatus nachdem rexit es ist teil
des eu binnenmarkts geblieben so soll
eine grenze zu irland ein mögliches
wieder aufflammen von gewalt verhindert
werden die unionisten wollen diesen
sonderstatus abschaffen da er
wirtschaftlich den weg richtung
vereinigung befördere doch auch hier hat
der wähler gesprochen eine mehrheit im
neuen parlament ist gegen eine
grundsätzliche neuverhandlungen mit der
eu damit ist das wahlergebnis auch eine
niederlage für die britische regierung
die brüssel seit monaten mit dem bruch
des brh exit vertragslos
in afghanistan schränken die
radikalislamischen taliban die rechte
von frauen weiter ein sie müssen in der
öffentlichkeit nun burka tragen einen
ganzkörperschleier bei dem auch die
augen bedeckt sind schon in den
vergangenen monaten hatten die taliban
weiterführende schulen für mädchen
geschlossen zehntausende frauen die für
die regierung arbeiteten verloren
außerdem ihre arbeitsplätze
in kubas hauptstadt havanna sind bei
einer explosion in einem luxushotel
mindestens 25 menschen ums leben
gekommen mindestens 64 wurden verletzt
schuld soll ein unfall beim befüllen der
gastanks des hotels gewesen sein das
gebäude stand nach einer krone bedingten
schließung schon länger leer sollte aber
in wenigen tagen wieder eröffnen zur
vorbereitung waren viele angestellte vor
ort
in der korona pandemie haben wir ja jede
menge daten preisgegeben wo wir wann im
restaurant waren ob wir uns infiziert
haben wie oft wir uns haben pieksen
lassen und da hat sich eine riesige
datenflut angesammelt in behörden beim
arbeitgeber auf unseren handys zeit zum
löschen sagen datenschützer sven rieken
digitaler frühjahrsputz kann so aussehen
nass und laut sein oder so in zwei
jahren pandemie haben sich viele check
ins und aus und registrierungen
angesammelt persönliche daten die
eigentlich längst gelöscht sein müssten
müssten ich möchte gar nicht wissen was
mit den daten passiert wenn wir mal ein
kaffeetrinken ja wenn wir uns irgendwo
einbuchen aus buchen also wir haben ja
das schon spuren hinterlassen ich denke
mal das wird den großen papierkorb
freuen und der wird am ende des tages
im kamin ein unfertiges das guckt sie
gar keine mehr widerspricht gilt auch
für die zahlreichen papierlisten zum
beispiel am arbeitsplatz auch alle
atteste in zusammenhang mit masken
pflicht befreiung oder impf und genießen
den status dürfen nicht in der
personalakte landen ein unfreundlicher
arbeitgeber könnte die nutzen können sie
in die personalakte eintrage könnte bei
späteren beförderungen oder
zuständigkeit entscheidungen unbewusst
oder bewusst diese
gesundheitsinformationen verwenden
ohnehin ist so ein digitaler
frühjahrsputz eine gute gelegenheit
ungenutzte apps und vor allem die
accounts dahinter zu löschen weil dort
überall daten sind die natürlich auch
von den unternehmen weiter genutzt
werden können aber vielleicht auch von
cyberkriminellen und dann vielleicht zu
identitätsdiebstahl oder zu anderen
nachteilen für den bürger genutzt werden
und das ist gefährlich die daten der low
carb jedenfalls sind diese woche
komplett verschwunden kontakt nach
verfolgung gibt es nicht mehr daher
wurden 41 millionen nutzerdaten gelöscht
die app ist damit auch ein fall für den
digitalen frühjahrsputz
die internationale raumstation iss eine
insel auf der alles in ordnung war so
nennt sie der deutsche astronaut
matthias maurer der das vergangene halbe
jahr dort verbrachte er heute morgen ist
er wieder in deutschland angekommen und
die welt ist eine andere als vor seinem
start im november über seine rückkehr
susanne freitag
er ist ein bisschen wackelig auf den
beinen sagt matthias maurer selbst seine
erste botschaft am boden ist dafür umso
klarer während seiner mission braucht
auf der erde der ukraine krieg aus ich
komme jetzt von einer insel in der auf
der alles in ordnung ist eine insel die
22 jahre lang als symbol für
internationale kooperation freundschaft
und friedliche zusammenarbeit der
menschen gestanden hat und von dort oben
aus zusehen wie die welt and lies das
ist natürlich sehr bedrückend unter
erschrecken sechs monate lang hat er
gemeinsam mit russen und amerikanern
zusammen gearbeitet und zusammen gelebt
es sind seine weltraum brüder sagt er
fast 150 experimente hat maurer gemacht
viele dienen dem klima und umweltschutz
mehrmals täglich schwebte er zum
weltraum fenster von dort hat er gesehen
wie sich der planet verändert hat man
sieht auch gletscher in gewissen
bereichen ja auch karten eingezeichnet
die wir jetzt nicht mehr erkannt haben
also meiner kenntnis auf den klimawandel
von oben und das ist natürlich alles
mit eigenen augen zu etwas zu sehen zu
spüren das ist noch mal viel viel viel
intensiver gestern frühmorgens splash
down vor der küste floridas plötzlich
wieder schwerkraft natürlich gibt's ein
paar annehmlichkeiten wie das essen von
einem teller wurde ich alles an deck
fliege wächst erhebt es ist natürlich
schön also für gewisse dinge ist die
schwerkraft toll für andere dinge kann
man auf sie verzichten matthias maurer
der vierte deutsche der auf der iss
geforscht hat er hat ein weiteres
kapitel deutscher raumfahrtgeschichte
geschrieben
sympathischer kerl so und zurück zur
erde und so sport und zudem cristian
genau los geht es im tennis alexander
zverev ist nach seinem frühen aus in
münchen wieder besser in schwung und
bleibt beim masters in madrid auf kurs
richtung titelverteidigung im
viertelfinale besiegte er den kanadier
verlierer alias im in zwei sätzen die
deutsche nummer eins vorne im bild
spielt sich immer mehr aus der formkrise
vor allem im ersten satz dominierte den
gegner 623 nach 33 minuten
mitte des zweiten durchgangs verliert
der weltranglistendritte beim stand von
4 2 1 kurz den faden der kanadier
gleicht auf doch zverev nach seinem
trainerwechsel auch mental wieder
stärker kämpft sich durch und holt sich
mit 7 zu 5 das ticket ins halbfinale
dort wartet kein geringerer als eine der
besten sandplatzspieler der welt der
grieche stephanus citipost
zum fußball erstmalig in der
bundesliga-geschichte am vorletzten
spieltag nicht alle partien parallel die
ergebnisse heute bisher kein heimsieg
greuther fürth unterliegt dortmund 1 3
hoffenheim leverkusen 24 dämpfer für
freiburg 1 zu 4 gegen union berlin köln
feier trotz des 0 2 1 gegen wolfsburg
und freut sich auf europa gestern
besiegte bochum bielefeld 21 alles zum
abendspiel hertha mainz ausführlich im
sportstudio morgen drei spiele und die
meisterehrung der bayern hinter dem
spitzenduo hat nun auch leverkusen die
champions league sicher der kampf um den
vierten platz für die königsklasse
freiburg kann morgen von leipzig
überholt werden union ist erneut für den
europacup qualifiziert ebenso köln
erstmals seit fünf jahren im keller kann
nachher härter den klassenerhalt sichern
stuttgart geht ins saison auf dem
relegationsplatz und würde mit einem
sieg bei den bayern bielefelds abstieg
besiegeln führt plant bereits für die
zweite liga und dort kann am abend
spitzenreiter schalke mit einem erfolg
gegen st pauli die rückkehr ins oberhaus
perfekt machen der hamburger sv rückt
durch das 2 2 1 gegen hannover auf
tabellenplatz 2 dank der besseren
tordifferenz vor die punktgleichen
darmstädter und bremen wo bei werder
morgen noch vorbeiziehen kann zu gast im
aktuellen sportstudio bei katrin
müller-hohenstein tischtennisspieler
dimitrij ovtcharov der wegen des ukraine
kriegs seinen langjährigen russischen
verein fakel orenburg verlassen hat und
noch zu leichtathletik verkorkster
saison einstieg für zehnkampf
weltmeister niklas kaul beim mehrkampf
meeting in ratingen gab der 24-jährige
kurz nach dem start des 400 meter lauf
wegen schwindel auch die vier
disziplinen davor liefen nicht wie
erhofft für die wm im sommer in den usa
ist er aber als titelverteidiger gesetzt
aber für die em in münchen im august da
muss er die norm knacken dadurch muss
sagen wir danke schön christin und wir
haben auch gute nachrichten vom wetter
morgen überwiegend sonnig und nächste
woche soll ich mir gleich von katja
horneffer das heute journal mit
christian sievers um 22 uhr 45 genießen
sie den samstagabend das gesamte heute
19 team bedankt sich fürs zuschauen und
sagt bis morgen um 19 uhr
[Musik]
guten abend damit die warmluft diese bei
uns so richtig in gang kommt braucht es
nicht nur ein hoch sondern auch ein tief
so kommt die warme luft aus
südwesteuropa zu uns schon morgen liegen
dort die höchsttemperaturen zwischen 25
und 35 grad bei uns wird heute nach kalt
besonders im norden da sinken die werte
auf 6 bis 2 grad droht also örtlich noch
einmal bodenfrost sonst gehen die
temperaturen auf 11 bis 6 grad zurück
rest einer kleinen kaltfront liegen
heute nacht noch zwischen berlin
brandenburg und der eifel etwas regen
fällt noch am alpenrand morgen gibt es
dann für die meisten einen sehr sonnigen
tag nur den mittelgebirgen kann sich
dann am nachmittag hier und da mal ein
kleiner regenschauer oder ein gewitter
bilden am alpenrand sieht dagegen trübe
aus da gibt es häufiger noch schauer und
gewitter die temperaturen liegen morgen
meist bei 14 bis 21 grad im südwesten
geht es dagegen bis auf 24 grad rauf und
am montag gibt es dann strahlenden
sonnenschein da bis zu 26 grad aber
schon am dienstag wird es dann von
nordwesten wieder wechselhafter und
damit auch wieder kälter wie sie aber
hier am temperatur und wettertrend für
frankfurt am main sehen können ist es
nur eine vorübergehende temperatur delle
schuld bis zum nächsten wochenende
steigen die werte bis 25 grad schönes
wochenende